thank you
hi everyone it's a pleasure to be here
to be here
so uh today we're going to be speaking
about you know the new opportunities
offered by sort of like the intersection
of ai and and protein design i have to
say it's a it's a very exciting uh
moment in terms of like innovation
because we are getting to the point
where
those innovations are really making an
impact and that's the part which i'm
most excited about
so
let's get started so
the idea here is uh i'd like to tell you
uh a bit more about what's happening in
the world of ai
we are at biologics uk but i think it's
important to get you a sense of
what is exciting and and why and what
has created this sort of ai jig or not
we'll discuss then uh you know biology
in in the age of ai what are the
implications of for biology and protein
design in particular and you know we're
just talking about democratization the
idea here is to
see what's the impact of this in terms
of making protein design more accessible
more efficient
and sort of like uh increasing the
impact of the amazing r d which is
taking place now and that's pretty much
our agenda for today
so
ai is basically you know like the best
way to look at it is it's a it's a
triple exponential
so it is indeed moving very very fast
it might feel sometimes there is a lot
of hype about ai but the reality is that
it is moving
faster than most people think
at the same time and the three
exponential there is effectively an
exponential uh on data data is growing
exponentially obviously
on compute
many of you have heard about moose law
but also and more interestingly on the
algorithms themselves and i'll tell you
more about these three aspects so first
about moore's law
you know there's this eternal debate
about is it ending or not it's the
notion that that compute power
effectively
doubles every uh every two years or so
and uh and the idea is like is is this
gonna change or not and the reality is
it's unlikely to change because if you
look at
you know like the fundamental limits of
physics using you know the best we know
about the world today we're still you
know something like 200 more years
of doubling before we reach the limits
so the paradigms might change we might
go from
silicon towards uh quantum computing and
the like but the notion is that you know
we have basically an incredible increase
of compute power which is happening all
the time
and
let's talk about data now data is very
important in the world of ai because
what you see historically is that
breakthroughs happen
when the data becomes available it's not
when a new technology sort of reached uh
that's a breakthrough from an
algorithmic point of view it's really
like when the data is there to nurture
that technological breakthrough if you
take recent examples for example like
the one before last
convolutional neural networks it's an ai
vision technology
it got invented in 1988 long time ago
but really like visual ai and ai that
can recognize objects people
scenes and settings really became
powerful only when the imagenet
competition which brought in one and a
half million images together
took place in 2010 and this led to many
breakthroughs in vision today you have
visual ai systems that have a better
vision than human and this is due to the
access to the data if you want now on
the algorithmic side remember we said
it's a triple exponential uh when it
comes to you know why ai is having such
a disruptive impact
well perhaps this point is less well
understood but the algorithms themselves
are improving all the time what do we
mean by improving if you think for
example like i take a visual task like i
said you know if you looked at how much
compute power you needed in
2012 to get to a particular result
in terms of like quality and accuracy
well in today in 2020 or 2021
you need actually 45 times less compute
so how did this happen well it happened
because effectively the algorithms the
methods keep getting better and better
all the time and so effectively
efficiency of ai algorithms if you think
of efficiency as the amount of compute
power i need to get to a given result
actually is doubling every 16 months
which is remarkable so it's sort of
another moore's law so think about it on
right side you have algorithms that are
more efficient all the time but compute
power itself increases all the time and
data increases all the time this is the
recipe for truly disruptive changes and
give you one example that made a ton of
noise last year
is openai's gpt3 so this is a what we
call a language model so it effectively
learns
english through by browsing the internet
and getting a lot of data in this
particular case
it's uh you know it it got trained with
400 billion words
and the result is pretty outstanding if
you look at results here i give you an
example this is actually a press article
you can take a look it's uh it's united
methodists agree to a historic split and
some debate religious debate whatever
but this has been completely written by
an ai and if it didn't tell you this you
would not guess that it would have been
written by an ei system so the new
methods are very powerful and
something which is also remarkable on
this breakthrough and this is why i'm
mentioning it here this language model
breakthrough is until recently in ai you
needed to do have a very time consuming
labeling of data so think about like you
want to recognize an image of a cat
versus a dog you would require to have
thousands of images of cat and someone
who says okay this is a cat
labeling for dogs the same way so this
is a manual process you have people who
need to go and label those data very
time consuming very inefficient what is
incredible about the breakthrough i'm
showing you here is that it required
zero labeling you're working from raw
data that is an incredible breakthrough
remember we said you know data the
explosion of data is key before we were
limited by label data only the recent
progress in ai which we call you know
self-supervised learning in this
particular case is you just feed the
data the system will learn directly and
by understanding the structure of that
data without any kind of
manual intervention if you want that is
revolutionary and why is it
revolutionary now let's talk more about
uh you know biology and i want to
explain why i've showed you these few
slides it's because this has a direct
impact into the way we can understand
you know for example protein sequences
so
effectively like on the left here i put
you an example which is
an english
example the animal didn't cross the
street because it was too tired and what
ai systems do now is what we call
language models in ai is they understand
the correspondence between the different
words in the sentence
and so for example it here refers to the
animal so you see the animal is
highlighted much more like the attention
is on animal so you're effectively
modeling directly correspondence between
different parts of the sequence and so
if you think about proteins and amino
acids well amino acids you could see
these are the words with whom you write
your language and your sentences and so
you can have basically correspondences
between different elements in a sentence
and sort of have the system discover
these by literally digesting a lot of
data so
how the it here in ai got related to the
animal is because this system so many
many sentences and understand understood
that it refers to what is happening like
who's the actor on the sequences etc but
purely from data and without any kind of
hint by a human or by expert so the
implication in in biology is profound
because this means and this has been
confirmed recently so the analogy what
i've showed you for english literally
works for the language of proteins and
this is a recent result from facebook ai
research which shows that if you train a
language model pretty much the same
style as what i've just showed you for
english but you train it on many many
protein sequences
think about something like in the order
of 250 million proteins 86 billion amino
acids again this is raw data there is no
context we didn't feed the ai any
information about you know which type of
proteins these are or all the like but
it definitely from sort of like
understanding what's happening on these
sequences it does understand structure
it does understand biological properties
that are quite important and how does it
do that
uh maybe i can say a few words about
this because you might wonder like okay
it sounds like magic like what's going
on here well the idea and the way those
systems work is
if i'm giving you an english sentence
and i hide a word okay
you know what is the the real word that
that that is in there because you got
the initial sentence for a start but
let's say for argument's sake i'm hiding
that word i'm gonna ask this system to
try to guess what this word was
and if you think about it to be able to
guess what is the correct word you
really need to understand the structure
of the sequence of the sentence and if
you do this at scale you basically
understand language and you build a
useful representation of language this
is exactly what we do also for protein
like training ai models on protein
sequences
and recent results show you that this
works very very well and that if you
look at the correspondence between
a given amino acid sequence and complex
properties such as for example structure
uh obviously we can get amazing results
these results are from uh google deep
mind which recently showed as you know
with alpha fold that you could from
sequence alone
understand the 3d structure the way the
protein folds which which is a problem
which which was open for a long time so
my message here is that we are in a now
in a new world where
having
an ai system
digest directly uh biological data
without contacts can be extremely
powerful and can get to great results
and of course you know that's a starting
point and on which you can then build
and develop different different models
different applications so
the problem with all this
is that this is very time consuming
requires ai experts requires a lot of
compute so
definitely you know these these models
don't come cheap and this is why like
it's typically tech giants who have uh
you know breakthrough innovation in this
so the question is how can we make this
useful to you like how can these two be
actually made
like
useful and accessible for an audience
which is uh like experts in biology but
people who don't have super computers or
have like super advanced understanding
of a very arcane ai technology and
that's where the notion of democratizing
protein design is so important if only
tech giants with incredible amounts of
compute power literally spending 10
million dollars of compute to solve a
problem
if that's the only thing we have well
that's not very interesting and very
useful for the
biology biology biologics community so
what we've done at instead is that we've
built deep chain as effectively a tool
that
accelerates and democratizes protein
design and if you think about it it's
like the intersection of ai innovation
biological expertise but also compute at
scale but in a format which is a lot
more accessible and importantly that the
level delivers concrete results in the
real world we have several projects on
which we got in vitro results so to give
you an idea of the type of projects that
we are working on
we worked on immunotherapies antibody
design
sask of two therapeutics we published a
research paper
on this cell signaling effectively like
any type of protein design
problem can be tackled with the type of
methods we are discussing here and in
particular like just to reemphasize the
complexity and this is something you
know well like the protein landscape is
very very big if you only took like a
hundred and like a protein with 150
amino acids and you limited yourself to
10 mutations this would still be the
same the number of solutions size of you
know equal to the number of atoms in
your body so
where ai systems can help is they can
help us navigate all this complexity for
and looking exactly for the exact
criteria that we are interested in and
obviously you know protein design is a
complex task and requires multiple
criteria to get to a success so of
course you have typically binding energy
sort of criteria but you want also your
proteins to express well you want them
not to be immunogenic you want them not
to be toxic so and you could think about
many other criteria as well so how could
you effectively
build up powerful criteria very quickly
and blend these in to get to results
when you're doing protein design
and that's where we have innovated with
this notion of deep chain workflow
where for the first time
we are allowing the user
or to create
scores or criterias in protein that are
coming either from the ai and machine
learning world so think about the
powerful models i just told you about or
from classic sort of like biochemical
simulation and blending this together is
very powerful because you can get for
example ai systems that have seen
all the human proteome and kind of have
an understanding of what looks like a
natural sequence or not this is not
something which is easy for a biologist
to do because effectively you need to
like go through so many protein
sequences you can do these things once
you have those scores you can then
optimize which means that
i have this criteria this criteria this
criteria and you are going to basically
ask the platform to get you
results protein sequences that obey to
all these different criterias which is a
complex search problem which we are
making much easier so let me make this
maybe a bit more concrete on the scoring
side of things like when we talk about
i'm going to create a powerful ai
scoring system as i mentioned if you
were to do this from scratch it would
take
months a lot of compute
definitely not an easy task from a
technical point of view and what we've
done in in in deep chain here
is that we actually allow the user to
use very powerful models that have been
already built
but sort of like fine tune them for a
specific task so let me give you an
example think about you're trying to
design
you know
a scorer to decide is this protein you
know
like human or is it a pathogen for
example so this is a sort of a baby
example
we know that we have today very powerful
models that have been trained on all
biology but they are not specifically
answering this question so what you do
in this particular case
is that if you have a data set in this
example here we have 96 000
like sequences which are
half of them are human half of them are
pathogens
and
we basically take this very large
pre-trained model and we just change the
ultimate insights the model basically
can tell you you know i can give you a
sense of
how those protein are represented and
then you just are matching those protein
representations to your particular task
which is tell me if this is human or
pathogenic so
doing this is actually very
straightforward you could actually do it
on a laptop if you have already the
pre-trained model ai model so this is a
notion we call which we call transfer
learning so let me give you an
equivalent like if you were in vision if
i have an ai system that understands
vision well then you want to teach it to
recognize a pringles box you just show
it a few examples of pringles and it
will learn very quickly what is a
pringles box because it already has a
general understanding that's the same
notion here but but for proteins so what
i'm saying here is that now it is
actually possible to do this very very
quickly so in a matter of certain cases
a few minutes or a few hours you could
build powerful ai models that would have
taken months by a team of experts to
build without
any sort of like a big expertise
required once you have those criteria
then we have what we call an ai designer
system which is going to do
multi-criteria optimization which to
give you protein sequences that obey to
this specific profile and this can be
complex criteria as we said such as
expression immunogenicity and and the
like so this is a way effectively to use
all the incredible breakthroughs of ai
without having to be an expert in the
field which helps a lot
behind the scenes
is
powerful uh like it's a computing
hardware to make this possible
at insta deep we are an nvidia elite
partner out of only six companies in the
world uh our supercomputer is positioned
here uh you know at uh at the same
location as nvidia's cambridge one which
you might have heard about which is the
most powerful ai uh like system in in
the uk but importantly
those tools are here to make it in a
completely seamless way to the user and
that means that somebody with no
background in high performance computing
or in ai can actually use those powerful
functionalities to solve this particular
concrete problem of protein design
they're interested in we also provide of
course molecular dynamic simulations
gromacs style which many of you are
familiar with and which are more classic
but if i were to summarize you now have
tools which allow you to do protein
design in silico using the powerful
breakthroughs that we have seen in ai in
a way that simply was not possible
before and
finally like to give you some some idea
about how we managed to to build this uh
my company insta deep is an emmy a
leader in ai we've been nominated in the
100 promising startups in the world and
what we're good at is
sort of delivering the promise of ai in
very concrete ways for our partners we
conduct research with uh google demand
so we know very well the amazing work
which is done by uh by google and and
deepmind but we have a focus on
applications and we work with large
names in particular biontech and you
know there is a lot of open research
that we publish but effectively we have
also in the team expert biologists that
can work with you to solve the specific
you know sort of like uh challenges you
have or you could use the platform from
scratch uh recently we signed a
strategic collaboration agreement with
bioentec uh you know the company behind
the pfizer biontech vaccine and as you
can see in the public press release you
know deep chain is
being
used in advanced projects with bioentech
so this is maybe my message is
ai in biology and in particular protein
design is a reality today it's having a
big impact so it's not a question of
you know
if or even when because it's happening
now the question is more like how can it
concretely help you solve the specific
problems that you are working on deliver
the right profiles of proteins to be
tested in vitro and this is a very
exciting time because
those models and those capabilities are
now
very powerful and and work so if i were
to sort of summarize a little bit this
presentation
and uh it's like
ai you know is there's a big disruption
coming from the ai world but i hope
after this presentation you get a better
sense of why is it such a disruption and
the answer is it's a triple exponential
data is growing exponentially and no you
don't even need data labeling it can
happen sort of without any labeling from
raw data which is incredible when you
think about it
and this is happening at the time when
biology is getting more personalized and
the cost of like human sequencing of the
genome is much smaller for example
but
compute power is growing exponentially
too
and importantly the methods are getting
better in an exponential way as well so
the impact is very profound and you can
start to see disruption happening in
biologics and in particular protein
design
but until now i think the feeling is
that those disruptions are coming from
big companies with incredible amount of
budgets and other and our goal uh with
my that my team and i is to make those
breakthroughs concrete and accessible to
help you solve those problems so we are
at the moment where protein design is
starting to get democratized with ai and
i think this is a very exciting time and
i can't wait to see sort of like the
breakthroughs we're going to have in in
coming years in terms of like
therapeutics vaccines or newly designed
proteins for specific tasks so thanks a
lot
for listening to the presentation we are
at booth 16 if you want to dig a bit
deeper into that
and uh happy to take some questions if
there are any
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for looking at me to give me
the heads up i'm about to finish you can
make your way up now so thank you for
that that was an excellent presentation
and as uh
as he engine we will now take whoa
okay so you are a great group i love
this this is brilliant okay so we have
quite a few questions for you we'll
start with the top one uh would deep
chain algorithm be able to predict
impact of selected post-translational
modifications
it could it could on a problem like this
we would um
typically like the approach we have is
uh
is we we work with uh with with with
data
that is either public or that is with
our partners
but
if you're looking at a prediction task
this is certainly something that we can
do
fantastic the next question is i don't
have a complete structure of the protein
i work on can you work with imperfect
models can you get a similar accuracy
absolutely the beauty of what we do is
that you don't need to have a protein
structure if you just have the sequence
of that protein we can work from there
fantastic
the next question is from pedro can you
predict antibody epitope mapping based
on the sequences of an antibody and an
antigen
yes this is again a prediction task and
you know we can work on these from from
sequence alone which which is a major uh
innovation if you want yeah definitely
so
if you only know the sequence of your
particular problem this is something we
can get started working on we also have
our own protein folding uh systems but
it's it's more than that it's a like
very powerful capability strain on large
amount of existing protein data so we
could do that fantastic
my projects involve confidential data
does your platform ensure data privacy
absolutely the way the platform works is
that you
you have your dedicated sort of
environment and
the sort of like we mentioned building
custom scores on on specific problems
those scores can be private to you if
you choose to we're also sort of having
a an open source
system and uh and this available on
github where people can contribute uh
scores which are public but
your
private scores can remain private and
uniquely accessible to you fantastic
could ai given current capabilities be
used to predict metabolic metabolic
pathways yeah that's an exciting
question i i think you know this is uh
sort of like what could be the next step
i would say today we're at a point where
we have a much improved grasp of protein
protein interaction
uh going into like full pathways and uh
trying to understand the equilibrium on
on those on those pathways
hasn't been done yet but i would expect
this to become more and more of a
possibility in coming years but
definitely great question it's a very
exciting thing for what we're not there
yet but that's the future that was asked
by aliado if you wanted to follow up and
continue that conversation afterwards
how much time did it take for your
customers to incorporate deep chain into
their pipelines to get satisfactory
experimental results
it can be very fast
literally
in some projects we got results
in less than a month so if you have a
well-formulated problem uh it's it's
super quick to get on board on deep
chain we didn't have time to demo but if
you come to our booth you can take a
look at deep chain interface is super
easy but we can also work with you to
get you to results uh you know as i said
in certain cases we got two
sequences delivered and then that were
later on confirmed confirmed in vitro by
our partners
and the whole process took less than a
month
fantastic and to end on the final
question from david perhaps you could
describe some examples of big impact in
the protein science field
i i think we're going to see big impact
everywhere from designing
anti-antibodies to personalized cancer
pipelines
uh
like
the the point the key thing about those
tools is that they are general purpose
so it's not like you know they they
would work for a problem and then you
know completely be irrelevant in another
so
definitely i mean
we're gonna see progress across all
those lines whether it's antibody design
understanding of
also
viruses and how they evolve that's a
very interesting field as well
and uh and developing de novo proteins
for for specific tasks so i think we're
gonna see progress literally across the
board fantastic and one final question
do you also use ai to define novel drug
targets
so
this this could be this could be
possible i just want to mention that
when it comes to deep chain we are
focused on uh proteins uh like we don't
do uh small molecules uh as as a a major
focus but if you know if you if you take
this question from a biologics
perspective and and look at protein yes
you can definitely use ai to uh define
uh you know new novel design drug
targets and and solve those yeah
fantastic that's probably a great way to
end and uh karim thank you for taking to
the stage and sharing more information
on your company thanks thank you very
much
[Applause]